- J'apporte des noix de pécan
- Des noix de pécan?
- Oui! Elle fait destetetes
aux noix de pécan immangeables.
Je plains son pauvre mari!- Yve!
- Salut, bienvenue!
- Vous êtes un des dirs s s s se
en ce moment. Tout d'abord,
comment vous expliquez votre
ascension des dernières années?
YVES BÉLANGER, l l l l l l l l e
- La chance, être là au bon
moment, des choses comme ça,
oui. Jean-Marc Vallée...
(rires)vivivivivivivivivivivivi!
- Xavier Dolan.
- Ah il y a aussi Clint
Eastwood.
- Oui,plus tard.
- On va en parler justement,
mais avant, qu'est-ce que
c'est un directeur photo?
la personne qui est responsable
de l'image du film, donc de
ce que j'appelle... je suis à
la fin de la chaîne alimentaire,
autres départements ont fait,
plus la performance des s.s.s.s.
Fait que c'est contrôler
l'éclairage, les cadrages et
du réalisateur, c'est sûr.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Votre passion pour le cinéma
bububububuté à l'âge de huit an.
Un électrochoc; vous avez vu
"2001 : l'odyssée de l'espace"..
- Oui.
- Quel impact ce film-là a eu
sur votre vie?
Je me souviens que déjà enfant,
j'étais fascleleleleles images,
mais j'ai eu carrément
une sensation physique.asasasase
par le cerveau, mais tout
rentrait par le corps puis
après ça... Je me souviens,
Comme directeur photo, moi c'est
ma plus grosse infauauauauaussi.
- Ah oui?
- Parce que Kubrick, commegrgrgs
cinéastes, surtout ceux qui ont
commencé avant les années 50,
il contrôlait carrément la
technique, l'image, le montage.
Moi, quand on me demande ma plus
photo, c'est pas un directeur
stststststst Stanley Kubrick.
- Tu connais pas Cheech?
- Je suis censé le coniiiiiiiiié
en quelque sorte avec "Cheech",
il y a eu "Gerry", mais le grand
décollage,ecececececececececece"
de Xavier Dolan.
- Oui.
- Le film "Dallas Buyers Club"
a vraiment été vwowowowowowowowc
Vallée que... Son décès
a ébranlé tout le Québec.
Pour vous, ça a été un deuil p .
Comment vous avez vécu ça?- Bie.
Je l'ai pas encore "processé",
comme on
Je me suis tenu très occupé,jejp
des autres. Mais,....
C'est ça, j'essaie de pas trop
y penser puis de... j'irai pas
lui. C'est vraiment lui qui
m'a fait connaîlelelelelelelele,
t'sais et tout.
Fait que... Là, on essaie bien
continue, et tout, fait que là
je suis bien gros là-dedans.
- Il y a rien sur cette terre
en 30 jours!
- Comment expliquez-vo
la chimie qu'il y avait entre
vous et Jean-Marc Vallée? Parce
bien, lui à la réalisation,vous,
dans "Dallas Buyers Club",
maiscomme "Big Little Lies".
- Moi, Jean-Marc, je l'ai
il avait fait quelques courts
métrages puis il commençait
avaient jumelés ensemble,étététt
devenus amis vite. Alors c'était
un ami
pense que c'était... parce qu'on
était très différenrsrsrsrsrsrss
il y avactctctctctctctctct l'un
pour l'autre. Moi, c'était...
Même si c'était super durdadadat
de la concentration, c'était pas
fait dans la joie et le bonheur,
et on était vraiment en train de
j'aimais ça. Pararararararararae
chose de... de merveilleux,
t'sais.
- Je pensais qu'il fallait avant
quququququququququelqu'un dans .
- Parallèlement à votre travail
avec votre ami Jeatrtrtrtrtrtrtc
votre idole Clint Eastwood.
- Oui.
- Sur deux films. Tout d'abord,
"Le cas Richard Jewell".
Comm
avec Clint Eastwood?lelelelelel.
- Intimidant quand même?
Votre idole!
- J'ai pas été intimidé.
Searararararararararararararara.
On était dans une peti
on l'attendait. Puis à un moment
donné, je l'ai entendu s'en
puis, t'sais, comme deux chienst
fait. C'était correct. T'sais,
il f
puis justement, de pas être
impressionné.
- Vous avez trdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdn
sur "Big Little Lies".
- Oui.
- Et c'est elle qui vous
pour la nouvelle série
ananananananananananangers".
- Oui...
- C'est vrai, ça?dididididididit
souvent un effet domino, dans
le sens que Nicole voulait moi,
mais ça adonnait bien parce que
" " " " " " " " " " " " " " " s
il me voulait, de toute façon.
- Oui, mais est-ce que c'est
Nicole qui a appelé, puis a dit
- Non, rendu là ils appellent
l'agent. Là, à
ils appellent l'agent.
Elle m'appelle des fois, mais
non.
isisisisisisisisisisisis vous
laisser parce que vous avez
des valises à faire. Vous par
pour un autre tournage.
- Merci! Ça fait plaisir.
- Oh! Une claquette de fin?